تجلي استقبل ضيف من بروكس العالم الفضاء
الدكتور عصام حجي دكتور اسئله كثيره تثار
الان فيما يتعلق
لنبداها لماذا منطاد اذا كان فعلا لتجسس
وليس عن طريق الاقمار الصناعيه
هي في نقطه مهمه
انه الصين لها عدد مهول من الاقمار
الصناعيه التي تستطيع ان تحصل بها على
المعلومات اذا لماذا هو المنطاد يعني انا
مش انا هنا اتمنى ان احنا نشوف الاجهزه
الموجوده فيه وبعد كده نشوف اذا كان فعلا
للتجارب العلميه او كانوا يستخدم في
الدجاجه اسوس المنطاد بشكل عام
مجموعتنا الاجهزه اكبر ويستطيع استحداث
وسائل جديده للاستشعار والتجربه في
المضمار الصناعيه اذا ميزه المنطاد ان هو
بوابه لاطلاق اجهزه استشعار حديثه في
المستقبل على الاقمار الصناعيه وهنشوف
خلال الايام الجايه تحليل الاجهزه
الموجوده على هذا المطاط هي اللي هتقول
لنا يعني ما نوع المهمه التي كان فيها هذا
المنطاد وارى انه في حاله التوتر الموجوده
في الان يعني يمكن بسبب التضارب المعلومات
زي ما بنشوف من من الاخوه الضيوف
الموجودين ولكن علينا ان ننتظر ماذا كان
يحمل هذا المنطاد من اجهزه طيب ايضا مما
اثير من الاسئله من خلال هذه التغطيه هو
كيف استطاع هذا المنطاد سواء كان ضالا
لطريقه او متقصدا لطريقه قطع كل هذه
المسافه وتصوير اماكن حساسه كما يقول
الجانب الامريكي ومن ثم تم الاعلان عن
رصده هل بالامكان ان يتجاوز ما لدى
الولايات المتحده من تكنولوجيا متطوره
للرقابه والرصد
اولا شيء مهم يجب اللي احنا نشوف انه
ارتفاع اللي بيطير عليه هذا المنطاد
بيجعله اضمن ليس من السهل ان هو يكون في
اجهزه
الرادار اثنين التكوين بتاع الماده اللي
فيها المنطاد وليس من الحديد
وبالتالي الجزء المعدني الموجود فيه ممكن
ما يسهلش برضو انه الرادارات العاديه التي
تستخدم في الملاحه الجويه تستطيع رؤيته
بسهوله ولكن تم فعلا دراسه هذا المنطاد من
وتم التعرف ان هو منتظمه داخل ولكن
الارتفاع الذي هو موجود عليه لا يجعله
يمثل اي نوع من
الخطوره لم يتعرف على يعني من اين من اي
مكان ينتمي هذا المنطاد وعايز اقول برضو
نقطه اوضح فيها انه التحكم في المناطيط
ضعيف جدا وليست هذه المره الاولى الذي يتم
فيها خروج منطاد عن مساره والسؤال ايضا
الاهم هو لماذا هم هذه المهمه فيها منطاد
في امريكا الجنوبيه في امريكا الشماليه
اعتقد ان ده السؤال السؤال الاكبر والاهم
واذا كان هما الاثنين طلعوا من من الاتجاه
اللي كان محدد لهم بسبب التغير في الرياح
او كانت هذه التجربه او هذه المهمه
تلزم وجود من تدين وكل هذه اسئله الصعب
الاجابه عليها قبل ما نشوف الاجهزه اللي
كانت موجوده على المنطقه
دكتور عصام
ما الذي يميز اجهزه
للتجسس عن اجهزه لاغراض علميه كما يقول
الجانب الصيني
سمعت من الضيوف الحديث كثير عن التصوير
ولا اعرف ما ميزه التصوير من المنطاد
بالمقارنه بالتصوير من الاقمار الصناعيه
او صيد بشكل عام ولكن ان ننسى ان هذا
المنطاد هو يعبر مناطق مغطاه بالسحب في
اغلبها هو لا يعبر مناطق في مناطق
الصحراويه والجافه التي التي ليست هي
مغطاه بالسحب
كانت التصوير
في حال الاجهزه كان يقوم بالتصوير او لا
ولكن التجارب الاهم التي
نقوم بدء الخاصه
لو
باستشعار المجال
الكهرومغناطيسي الموجود في هذه في الغلاف
الجوي والذي يساعد في تطوير تكنولوجيا
الاتصالات الحديده مثلا ويساعد في لو
كان فاكيد
هيحب اكتر من هو يكون بيصور في شيء معين
في هذه المنطقه في اعتقادي انه ايضا دكتور
عصام
طيب ايضا في ظل وجود
الاقمار فيها من تكنولوجيا حتى فيما يتعلق
بدراسه الظواهر الطبيعيه متى يتم اللجوء
للمنطاد في ظل وجود الاقمار الصناعيه
المنطاد في رايي الشخصي ان هو يستطيع ان
ان يكون افضل من القمر الصناعي في في انه
في في في التقاط الموجات
الكهرومغناطيسيه البي اتش اف بيسموها يعني
لو في حد بيستخدم هذه الموجات في
العسكريه او غيره او
بعض التصوير بهذه الموجات في هذه الحاله
نحتاج ان نطير في هذا الارتفاع امر
الصناعي موجود
طبقه من الغلاف الجوي بتسمي بتسمى
الايونسفير وهذه الطبقه تمتص هذه الاشعه
اذا لا يستطيع القمر الصناعي تسجيل او
التقاط الاتصالات بالترددات الموجيه
الطويله ويتم هذا في هذا الامر استخدام
البالونات مثل هذا البالون وهذا ما يفسر
ان الاجهزه التي موجوده على هذا البالون
بهذا الحجم نحن نتكلم على اجهزه باحجام 30
متر فلون ننظر ما هي الاجهزه التي تحتاج
تكون بهذا الحجم هي الهوائيات التي تستخدم
الترددات الموجيه الطويله التي التي تعمل
بها
اجهزه الاستشعار الراداري سواء المدني او
العسكري
ارجو ان تبقى معي الدكتور عصام الكثير من
الاسئله العلميه خاصه في ظل وجود
الروايتين الصينيه والامريكيه في الجهه
المقابله تحليق المنطاد الصيني فوق
الولايات المتحده قبل اسقاطه وما احاط
بذلك من جدل يعيد الى الواجهه حروب التجسس
التي تخوضها دول لاصدقاء معلومات حساسه من
الخصوم والاعداء فما هي ادوات الصين في
ذلك لم تعد المناطيط تشكل منصه تجسس مثلى
منذ نهايه القرن التاسع عشر لكن خبراء
غربيين يعتقدون ان لدى الصين تجسس يتم
توجيهها بالذكاء الصناعي مما يضمن استعاده
البيانات التي تجمعها بالاضافه الى صعوبه
اسقاطها تملك الصين ايضا اقمارا صناعيه
متطوره للتجسس يعتقد انها تحلق فوق
الولايات المتحده كل يوم وتلتقط الصور
وتجمع اشارات الراديو وبيانات
وقد اطلقت اطلقت اربعه حديثه منها العام
الماضي كما ان بيجين لديها حمله تجسس
احترافيه ضخمه تعتمد على عملاء ميدانيين
ينشطون في الولايات المتحده والدول
الحليفه لها الى جانب جيش من قراصله
الشبكه العنكبوتيه يعمل على اختراق انظمه
الحواسيب والبيانات في الهيئات السياديه
والمؤسسات الحساسه في تلك الدول ويركز
نشاط التجسس الصيني بحسب مراكز غربيه
متخصصه على سرقه اسرار تجاريه وتقنيه
لاكتساب المعرفه التكنولوجيه التي تشغل
اقتصاد بيجين وتعزز تحديها للنظام
الجيوسياسي الغربي كما يمكنها هذا النشاط
في المجال العسكري من رصد التحركات
الاستراتيجيه للقطع الحربيه ونشاط القواعد
العسكريه الامريكيه المنت في منطقه المحيط
الهادي
اعود برتقالي ضيفي من بروكس عالم الفضاء
الدكتور عصام حجي حتى الان بعض التقارير
الاستخباراتيه الغير رسميه من داخل واشنطن
تقول وترجح بان هذا المنطاد يحمل
تكنولوجيا جدا متقدمه طبعا لها علاقه
بمجال التجسس عندما نتكلم عن تكنولوجيا جد
متقدمه ما الذي يعني ذلك
في اعتقادي انه تفسير لحجم الهوائيات
الموجوده
التي نراها في تصوير المنطاد حجم هذه
الهويات يعني ان هو
هناك تجارب تخص موجات الرادار الطويل
المدى التي يا اما تستخدم في الاتصالات
العسكريه او
بتستخدم في رادارات ما وراء الافق وهي
انظمه ردريه بحريه
اما تستطيع
تحركات للقطع البحريه او للقطع العسكريه
ما وراء مسافات ابعد من الرادارات العاديه
وقد يكون هذه التجربه يا اما تطوير لهذه
المنظومه يا اما استشعار لمنظومه موجوده
ومره اخرى بكرر
انه ان انت تطير بمنطاد على ارتفاع ما
يقرب من عشرين كيلو متر من 20 ل 25 وهو
عشان تكون
تحت الايونوسفير بتاع كوكب الارض اللي هو
بيبتدي من مئه كيلو متر يعني انت من 200
كيلو متر وهذا لا يمكن
القمر الصناعي لانه هذه
الطبقه الموجوده من 100 متر لغايه من 100
كيلو متر لغايه 400 كيلو متر تنتص هذه
الاشعه وبالتالي لا يمكن القيام بهذه
الدراسات بسهوله من الاخبار الصناعيه
ونحتاج ان نطير على ارتفاعات اقل من 100
كيلو متر فبيكون المنطاد وخصوصا المنطاد
الستوسفير هو الافضل ليه ان هو احتاج ينزل
لمسافه 20 25
كم اعتقادي ممكن ان ده لانه عشان يقدر
يحسن نوعيه الاستقبال في الهويات الضخمه
اللي كانت موجوده على المنطاد
شكرا لك يا دكتور عصام حجي كنت معي من
بروكسل